-Let's talk about what
people are talking about,
what's going on in the news
right now.
Over the weekend, it came out
that President Trump's
approval rating is at 36%.
[ Audience groans ]
But Trump defended the number,
saying that it was "almost 40."
[ Laughter and applause ]
-Come on!
-He did.
"Almost 40."
36%.
Then he said,
"And if you read 36 upside down,
it looks like 93,
which is almost 100.
So I'm doing amazing.
Almost 100.
In Upside Down World."
But did you see that last week,
Trump's son Don Jr.
tweeted screenshots of e-mails
from the Russian lawyer
who offered sensitive info
to his dad's campaign?
When he heard that his son
tweeted about
an ongoing investigation,
Trump was like, "The student
has become the master."
[ Laughter and applause ]
-That's it.
-"Wax on. Wax off."
[ Laughter ]
[ Laughs ]
In the meantime, the president
has hired a new lawyer.
Did you see this guy?
-Yeah.
-[ Laughs ]
It's unbelievable.
He's hired a new lawyer.
His name is Ty Cobb.
[ Laughter ]
It's his real name.
Dude, Quest, I swear, man.
-Come on!
-His real name --
His name is Ty Cobb.
To oversee
the White House response
to the Russia investigation.
Show a picture. This is real.
That is the lawyer.
[ Laughter ]
Because nothing says
"My client's innocent"
like a lawyer who looks like
he's wearing a disguise.
What is going --
[ Cheers and applause ]
"He's innocent!"
I don't know if he's
giving Trump legal advice
or talking to him
about "diabeetus."
[ Laughter and applause ]
[ Laughs ]
"Come over to this side
of the porch."
Trump just had his first trip
to France,
and at the end of his visit --
Did you see this?
He shook hands with
French President Emmanuel Macron
for a really long time.
Did you see?
It's pretty strange.
We didn't do anything to this.
Watch this video.
Here he goes.
"How you doing?
Nice to see you.
Pleasure to meet you.
Yeah. How you doing?
All right. Good. Yeah."
Tap, tap, tap.
There you go. Pull.
A little yank, a little yank.
Yeah, that's good.
And he's still holding.
He's like -- This is real.
And then
the French First Lady --
He gets her involved,
and they're grabbing.
Now it's the circle of life.
Now -- And then you again.
You get tapped.
That's it. 30 seconds.
30-second handshake.
That looked like a lame sitcom
where two characters
accidentally glue their hands
together.
You know? It's like, "Ugh, ugh!
What are you going to do? Heh!"
[ Applause ]
You guys, last night
was the season premiere
of "Game of Thrones."
[ Cheers and applause ]
No spoilers. No spoilers.
But I saw that HBO's streaming
site crashed during the episode.
[ Audience oohs ]
That's how crazy
this show has gotten.
They're killing off
websites now.
-Really?
Everything --
-They don't care.
-You don't know
who's going to survive.
-Winter is here.
-I saw that today
is World Emoji Day.
Did you guys know that?
Yeah, of course.
So in honor of that...
[ Laughter ]
...we did some research
and found out
what was the inspiration
behind some popular emojis.
-Really?
-Yeah, for example,
this emoji was inspired
by Angela Merkel
when she was listening
to Donald Trump.
-Wow. Wow.
[ Applause ]
-This emoji was inspired
by Ben Carson
at an important meeting.
[ Laughter and applause ]
And finally, this emoji
was inspired by Donald Trump
when he's asked about Russia.
[ Laughter and applause ]
More trouble
for United Airlines.
-Oh.
-Yeah.
The rapper ScHoolboy Q says
that they actually flew his dog
to the wrong city.
Yeah. Then I guess
on the flight back,
the dog had a fight over a seat
with Ann Coulter.
-Really?!
[ Cheers and applause ]
-That's right.
-Ah.
-Yeah.
-"This bitch gets my seat?"
[ Laughter ]
It's a dog.
Get this. On Friday,
a group of 40 turtles
caused delays on the runway
at JFK Airport.
On the bright side, the turtles
were moving so slow,
they got hired
to work at LaGuardia.
"That's amazing.
They're that slow.
It's amazing.
-Hey-yo!
-They're that slow!"
This isn't good, guys.
Millions of
Sabrett's hot dogs --
I love Sabrett's hot dogs.
Millions of Sabrett's hot dogs
that are sold here on the street
in New York City
are being recalled because they
contain small pieces of bone.
[ Laughter ]
While the foreman
at the factory was like,
"Hey, has anyone seen Jeff?
[ Cheers and applause ]
When you see him,
tell him he's fired!"
-[ Laughs ]
"He hasn't been here
since the machine clogged up!"
-[ Laughs ]
"Oh, Jeff's wedding ring.
He must have dropped it
in the hot-dog mixture!"
-"He's eloping
with a different lady!"
-"I'll go bring it to his house.
I'll take the same shortcut home
that Jeff takes."
Whoa-ah!
[ Laughter ]
[ Laughs ]
-"Where's Gary?!"
-"When you see Jerry,
tell him he's fired!
Hey, Jerry's hat. He must
have dropped it in the hot dogs.
I'll take the same shortcut
that Jerry takes!"
[ Laughter ]
[ Laughs ]
It's just -- Okay.
I don't know.
[ Laughter ]
Guys, millions of hot dogs
have been recalled
after small pieces of bone
were been found in them.
Street vendors are doing
their best to keep sales going.
Just check out some of the new
signs that they've been using
I saw today on the streets
of New York.
-You saw them?
-I walked around.
I brought my camera.
I took photos.
-Of all the times?
-All the vendors.
-All over the city?
-Yeah.
-Well, how nice of you.
-I have one of those nice
Kodak Brownie cameras.
-Oh, my gosh!
-Yeah.
It's a beautiful old camera.
I got to get it developed.
-132-millimeter film.
-[ Laughs ]
I walked around today,
and they're trying
to keep business going.
-God bless them.
-So let's take a look
at some of the signs they have.
This first one says, "Relax.
These hot dogs were made
years before
the bone problem started."
Don't worry about it.
-Yeah.
-Years ago.
-This next one says, "So what?
You got bones inside you, too."
-Yeah.
What's your problem?
[ Applause ]
I like this one.
This one says,
"You want a boneless hot dog?
What are you,
the queen of friggin' England?"
"What are you?"
-No!
"The queen of friggin' England."
Here's the last one here.
It says,
"This cart is the original
famous bone-filled
hot dog cart."
That's the one to be at.
That's the one.
[ Applause ]
Oh, this really
made me laugh, guys.
Last week, a man in Texas got
himself trapped inside an ATM.
Did you hear about this?
This is insane.
This is a movie.
This is fantastic.
This is finally my one-man show.
I get to do this.
Trapped in an ATM machine.
And he was slipping people notes
through the receipt slot
that said "Help."
People taking money out
were like,
"I knew my balance was low,
but what?
What do you mean, 'help'?
Oh, man. I'm in trouble, man."
[ Applause ]
That's right.
The guy got stuck in an ATM.
The man said that he was
excited to finally eat
then got himself trapped
in a vending machine.
He's like, "Press B12!"
Guys, we have
a great show tonight.
It's really fun!
The Roots right there!